getting a show from script to screen is
a fast and furious process some crews
make 13 episodes of scripted TV and the
same amount of time it takes to make a
single blockbuster movie so how do they
do it this process applies to all types
of scripted TV shows both dramas and
comedies but we're going to use an
hour-long drama with a 13-episode season
as an example let's say you're the
showrunner this is what the next year of
your life is going to look like first
things first you and the writers break
the story meaning you plot out the major
moments of the season and then you
assign writers to break the story for
each episode after multiple drafts the
script around 45 pages is created that's
about 600 pages of material for the
whole season at this point episodes are
assigned to directors and directors of
photography who begin planning on their
own and then there's the art department
they're in charge of the whole look of
the show let's say the show takes place
in New York City in 1980 the art
department researches the period so that
everything as big as buildings and cars
and as smallest magazines and jewelry
look realistic now let's get shooting to
shoot 45 pages of material in about
eight days you need a serious schedule a
traditional script isn't all that
helpful to a crew so first each scene is
assigned a location time of day and
actors after all these factors are
prioritized the result is a document
called a white schedule once shooting
begins every episode requires the table
read that's when the whole cast gets
together and reads the script from
beginning to end at this point the
director works with the director of
photography to correctly block all the
actors and every scene is shot from
multiple angles a one-minute scene and a
show could easily take a few hours to
shoot now you might not think your
typical drama would have a lot of visual
effects but something as little as a TD
playing in the background of a scene
requires post-production work ever hear
the phrase we'll fix it in post
here we go a post-production team is
comprised of editors sound designers
visual effects artists and all of the
assistants and coordinators that go
along with them editors make the first
cut of the episode and give it to the
director then the director's cut goes to
the showrunners the showrunners give
notes create a producer's cut and that
goes to the studio which then becomes
the network cut during this entire
process things like that TV with the
green screen get pushed through visual
effects once all of the edits are final
a color corrector and sound designer
begin to work their magic the dialogue
needs to be cleaned up sound effects put
in and the entire edit needs to be mixed
ok we're almost done it's now several
months after writing began and the
episode fully mastered gets service to
broadcasters around the country but the
rest of the show isn't finished every
episode is finalized just a few weeks
and sometimes just a few hours before it
premieres